in your book you write about contract
negotiations a little more recently for
the jackass movies but what was that
first contract negotiation in the early
or was there no negotiations there's no
negotiation there was never a
negotiation until the fourth movie
really I always just found out what I
was going to get the first whole season
of Jackass on MTV I made less than 1500
bucks
wow with no uh like you know residuals
or anything like that it was it was just
like that and um through the rest of the
TV series The First movie and the second
movie
I never even attempted to to counter and
offer to improve it and
I got sober right before the third movie
and I and my lawyer that was the first
movie where I had a sophisticated
attorney
he said this is you know this isn't a
bad deal you should be able to get
better
I was told by like the powers that be
and and sort of uh the jackass world
like to take this or you're not going to
be in the movie and I freaked out I told
my lawyer like I take it you know like
and uh and I I was
for the next 10 years that kind of
bothered me I was like man I didn't
stand up for myself I
and so I wanted to make a big show of I
wanted to make up to the younger version
of me that never did stand up for myself
and really try to get a better deal for
the fourth movie
which got a little complicated yeah it
went really sideways you read the book
to find out I think it's what I would I
would tell our audience but in the early
days were you just happy to be there was
it like the exposure was the payment for
sure I mean there's definitely uh
you know a thing called paying your dues
I felt that I was being taken advantage
of in the very beginning but
my position on that was that hey you
know what like
they're kind of making a monster out of
me by giving me all of this attention
when I say I'm an attention I
really really mean that like so
genuinely that like I was never
particularly motivated by Financial
again I just wanted notoriety attention
[Music]